[Music]
I've told you this over the years I
really love the the Stifler character I
always really loved that your you're
such a you're such a jerk but instead
it's such a fat fun in such a funny way
your character too and and and so you
root for him even though he's so
obnoxious yeah it's another way to put
it yeah
do you like now you realize like you're
gonna play other roles you have played
of the roles but there's a fondness in
the culture for Stifler and you're
always gonna be Stifler - some people
does that bother you no yeah no I mean
I've done four of a mile I love the
movie I love the character and it's it's
given me a career and a life I never
would imagine but the funniest things
are like when when like people come up
and say the weirdest stuff to me and I
remember I was doing not long ago I was
going through security at an airport and
so I was waiting for my luggage to go
through and and the female security
guard goes and I was really early in the
morning I was exhausted she goes what's
the capital of Thailand and I was like
goes
Bangkok
and I was like oh it's line and she hits
you down there she was about to yeah
jump back you know I was so confused
that I remembered it was the line that I
said in American Wedding like thanks I
guess what the hell is that's what I go
through do the string dance I get people
like you find make me do that but you
get punched in the in the nuts by
security that's that's rough it's hard
being an actor alright well we have a
clip here from the film American Reunion
and tell us about this scene I will it's
a classic scene of Stifler giving some
wisdom to Jimbo yeah that's all I'll say
about that all right let's take this
clip American Reunion after this drink I
got to go home Jim there's a smoking-hot
eighteen-year-old girl over there that
used to babysit and you're not gonna do
anything about that need I remind you
that I am married to Michelle exactly
dude you can take what you learn from
Keira bring it home and apply to
Michelle you do care about your marriage
don't you Junior what are you talking
about Stifler I'm not gonna cheat on my
wife yeah I'm a father
yeah that's perfect chicks love a father
figure keep playing that card dude it's
not a card it's the truth oh you know
just Jim was just saying how much fun he
had taken care of you ladies why don't
we keep them some time to catch up
[Music]
necessary we should all hang out
together we all just nibbler just be her
daddy
you
[Applause]